et sur ce plateau Guillaume lascon
jarrias bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
historien militaire professeur à Paris
Sorbonne et ancien cherchera l'OTAN on
va essayer de prendre un peu de recul
avec vous le constat non après c'est que
Vladimir Poutine n'a évidemment pas
atteint ses objectifs quels ont été ses
principales erreurs selon eux va te
programmes effectivement alors déjà à
mon avis de 3 erreurs la première c'est
d'avoir sous-estimer la capacité de
résistance des Ukrainiens très
clairement il pensait que les forces
russes allaient être accueillies en
héros alors ça c'est peut-être une autre
dimension c'est à dire que il s'est
probablement inventé un discours sur
l'Ukraine qui était les ukrainien le
lien particulier qui unit l'Ukraine à la
Russie et cette dimension historique
s'est réveillée en fait totalement
fausse parce que tout simplement
l'Ukraine s'est séparé de l'Union
soviétique il y a longtemps et que la
nouvelle génération n'est plus
l'ancienne et que malgré les liens
malgré les attaches familiales et tout
ça ce lien
qui a permis en fait la résistance
ukrainienne n'avait pas été saisi et je
pense que c'est le le premier biais le
deuxième c'est d'avoir surestimer son
armée et là on vient à deux travers une
espèce de culture du mensonge
institutionnalisée dans l'armée russe
qui fait que probablement il n'y a pas
outre la corruption généralisée il n'y a
pas de culture du compte-rendu on ne dit
pas ses chefs la vérité on leur dit ce
qu'il souhaite entendre et donc ce
niveau de mensonge remonte probablement
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'État et
donc il y a eu cet effet de surprise
puis la troisième chose c'est que
l'effet de rapidité et de vélocité dans
lequel il s'était lancé donc une
opération spécialité de trois jours qui
débouche sur un conflit d'une année
c'est tout simplement parce que
probablement il a voulu voir trop grand
la première erreur qu'il a faite ayant
été de disperser ces troupes sur
quasiment cet axe de manœuvre ce qui
était pour une petite force offensive
possible sur un seul axe c'est révélé
absolument
ultra dimensionnant pour la même force
mais diviser sur sur cet axe et donc il
y a il y a cet échec et donc ce cette
transformation véritablement de la
guerre après quelques conquêtes quand
même il faut bien voir que encore
aujourd'hui 20 % du théâtre
ukrainien et du pays qui l'Ukraine est
occupé ce sont les dernières estimations
entre 15 et 20% c'est ça alors ça me
rend entre 15 et 20% une partie lait en
fait depuis 2014 et là encore il faut
bien le rappeler ce qui est une partie
du don-basse bien sûr est-ce que nous
voyons en fait aujourd'hui ne guerres
que la continuation de ce qui s'est
passé depuis 2014 2022 n'existerait pas
c'est pas eu 2014 la guerre dans
laquelle les Ukrainiens sont c'est pas
une guerre d'une année c'est une guerre
de une année plus les huit années qui
ont précédé oui c'est important de
l'expliquer aussi pourquoi sur France 24
on ne vous écrit pas un an de guerre
puisque la guerre en fait elle a
commencé en 2014 avec l'annexion de la
Crimée c'est toujours important de le
préciser c'est une journée
ultra symbolique mais l'une des
informations à retenir c'est donc cette
livraison par Varsovie de ses premiers
chars léopards à l'Ukraine ça va changer
quoi rapidement sur le terrain ça va
changer quelque chose alors ça peut oui
il peut y avoir un effet tactique et
symbolique aussi de la livraison de char
mais il faut bien rappeler quand même
trois choses d'abord livrer des chats
c'est pas on livrait une poignée c'est
en livrer beaucoup un escadron c'est
même pas plus que littéralement si on en
livre et selon les spécialistes il
faudrait entre 250 et 300 machines
modernes pour véritablement atteindre au
niveau de ce qu'on appelle un
gamechanger c'est à dire un niveau de
transformation conséquent qui permettent
de transformer et d'obtenir un véritable
effet stratégique sur sur le terrain
donc déjà rappelle qu'un escadron c'est
14 au charme il faudrait quoi 20 escades
donc il faudrait en réalité l'équivalent
d'une grosse brigade de char et le
deuxième chose c'est que Richard c'est
bien mais un char tout seul dans
l'environnement
ultra létal du champ de bataille il ne
sert à rien s'il n'est pas entouré ou
survoler par des drones accompagnés de
véhicules d'infanterie s'il y a pas de
véhicules de génie qui permettent de
déminer devant bref un char tout seul
c'est une carcasse quand il est bien
entouré quand il est capable de
manœuvrer et donc d'exploiter derrière
ça devient un outil effectivement très
efficace puis un troisième chose c'est
que un char moderne c'est aussi la
complexité d'un système de commandement
latéral horizontal vertical dans toutes
les dimensions ce qui veut donc dire que
il faut aussi penser que cette ce
système là il va devoir le rattacher à
un système de maintenance qui lui est
extrêmement compliqué si ces chars là il
faut les remettre en condition ou les
remettre à ton condition prolon pas en
Ukraine mais à nouveau en Pologne ou
plus loin quid du coup de cette
contre-offensive annoncée par vos
ledimir zelens qui allait crédible selon
vous alors elle est crédible
[Musique]
tout ça tout ça c'est compliqué et même
si ça a lieu il faut que ça puisse
déboucher si comme le disait linsky et
son plus haute sur la fin de la guerre
et bien il faut que d'abord il y ait une
vraie victoire merci beaucoup Guillaume
lasconjari merci à vous d'avoir répondu
à nos questions aujourd'hui